reject nation we're gonna watch all of
us are dead
one by five it's a short one it's only
56 minutes compared to its usual two and
a half hours ah hit that like button if
you've been enjoying our reactions that
mean a lot helps us out in the algorithm
also subscribe and click the
notification bell you know if i want to
react for episode six is up i hope you
stayed around for the intro because not
sure when the following one's coming
kind of a weird week because book of
boba fett is the finale and then i'm
gone for two days so
yeah just uh keep a lookout
yeah full-length watch alongside you
sync up with the time code over our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of crap
over there as well thanks for all
becoming superjects and them handsome
boys over at prepper thanks for being
some some good devils to us all right
guys check it out
[Music]
[Music]
so calm cool collected no issues killing
is she looking for someone specifically
so cove it happened in the same world
with the zombies
what the hell guess i don't care for the
wisdom they don't want those refugees
boys
[Laughter]
what if he's a real influencer
i wouldn't be surprised
so now this is like very topical yeah
oh good do you freaking show your damn
mistletoe
i like that one
i wonder if the creator of the show came
up with this idea when he was in high
school
what me my friends do
oh my god he's an agile zombie
wow
this is an obstacle course
[Music]
a loser is better damn stunts
oh
jeez
oh my god
wow nothing will cause this guy to fall
my man
hit him with it yeah
and the phone's still intact it's a good
phone case
why didn't you run man yeah
why didn't you run savor it now
no
oh good they think he got away
wait it out man
that's scary
no
no there's no time to wait it out keep
going no no no no no
excellent use of book
no time to think start running start
running please start running run please
start running run
nice oh
archery class thank you
supplies
[Music]
but people need help
glass this guy you're gonna have to go
such a dangerous ass rope climb um
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
you messed up
[Music]
oh no damn i think get out of there
[Music]
oh my god they
found the
[Laughter]
what
he's killing immediately
can't take a chance
the baby came at me you saw it
can't leave the baby behind
oh no she gonna get bit no
oh god damn it dude
oh
[Laughter]
oh he's got to tell her
[Laughter]
still miss gongsu find your motivation
man
oh dude for the love of god
[Music]
dude he's so cool
jeez
rock and roll will save us
[Laughter]
she wasn't bitter right no
well not that we know about i'm gonna do
some flashback that show she got bit
[Music]
the perfect time to
panic bet someone there has a special
cameo
i hope she and the archer girl get
together by the end of this
i thought they're going to be landing on
trash that's like one shot
damn
[Laughter]
oh boy
[Applause]
[Music]
reveals
yeah i'm really afraid now
how far can this thing go yeah what's
the range jesus
oh is that your pops yeah
[Music]
damn that's hard
[Music]
that's heartbreaking
don't crash the truck
comes out
it's a wide margin
it's like flying spirit airlines
peering into economy
why are his eyes not transformed okay
thank god i was gonna say if he's the
[ __ ] cure
oh he could be i don't know
[Applause]
what he's like her you gotta be [ __ ]
me what
what
come
on
this [ __ ] guy why does the show love
this guy so much the power of evil helps
him persist
fundamentally
[Music]
oh god oh
god damn it i wonder what happens if he
runs into the girl with all the phones
would he still crave human flesh though
that's a great question
[Laughter]
you sick son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that is oh my god that is as far as
villains go
that is so frustrating that is
yeah
that is so frustrating
frustrating
[Laughter]
right when you think i knew it was too
rewarding when he died when he died
still waiting for the show to get boring
i know oh my god i heard this was the
level package
her daughter don't worry like four
through six i'm like four five pretty
damn entertaining if you ask me
six is just gonna be like one person
alone in a room no zombies
yeah totally new character that we don't
know yet
well it's what they're what the show's
doing is cool because they're taking
this
what they're pretty much doing is doing
like a whole bunch of zombie movies in
one
you know like you have your dawn of the
dead like situation where you're stuck
in a and a big location with a lot of
zombies and then now what we're doing is
exploring
the outside part with the military
and the quarantine zones
and how the army and all them are
handling it where the public are finding
refuge
and watching how that's also a [ __ ] show
on its own yeah we'll unrest with
refugees yeah yeah and it takes the time
to explore the the finer details of that
and then now also at the at the top of
this episode exploring
the
the real world and how they'd react to
it if they're not involved
as like they directly reference the you
know pandemic and then you're you're
seeing how that's also factoring in here
because the zombie outbreak hasn't
spread everywhere yet so you got the
people pulling the pranks you got the
fake news misinformation being spread
out you know of how this can happen so i
i'd be curious to see if the show does
go down that path of of like
people uh attacking uh you know how like
when the
when the virus is real in the real life
when it first broke out there was a lot
of like
um racism towards asian people that was
occurring yeah you know absolutely and i
don't know if that was going to hit like
too real for this show or something like
that
uh but you know it's like people jump to
conclusions about like it it's it even
now you know like people sometimes cough
or sneeze like you got covered
everybody says
and you know i'd be interested to see
how people if they do something like
that here because it seemed like they
were touching on something that was very
topical intentionally of like all right
this is dealing with a virus outbreak we
just had a real life virus outbreak
affect the world
and now we're seeing how it's being
handled here too and like the way they
handle the turns of things of um
of uh i lost my train of thought
but take it away
yeah i mean
weaving in and out of all these things
no i i think it is really impressive
because this they've slowly been
introducing the macro scale along with
the micro scale that we've been existing
on and so yeah in this episode it feels
like the most engaged that aspect of it
has been seeing how they're dealing with
martial law seeing how they're cutting
off the city because of all the fake
reports and things coming out of it and
and it's funny because reading in the
comments again i i some folks were like
oh man i guess really ham fisted with
some of this stuff but thus far i mean
i felt like they've managed to
really gracefully weave in and out of
both of these stories and keep them both
tense and percolating and sort of you
know
kinetic in a way while also giving you
these certain little moments of poetry
whether it be uh
you know just seeing like the constant
expectation of like i'm an assembly
woman you should have like the best
carpet rolled out for me and they're
constantly like we're doing the best we
just don't have
much to work with
and uh and yeah watching as the
situation expands and watching as these
characters it's like you know you've got
uh the girl at school and her dad and
they get further and further from each
other and he's keeping on trying to get
in contact with her somehow but yeah
like they've managed to
keep this situation that feels really
immediate and very tangible
growing now in a way that gives you more
narrative omnipresence because you're
cutting from place to place more often
but that still feels like they basically
took a zombie like you said a bunch of
zombie movies with the overarching theme
of okay and i know other movies have
done this but this sort of okay how
would this really go down in our world
today with our you know human
with like the quirks of our cultures as
well as just our human response
mechanisms how would this all play out
what would everybody be doing what would
everybody try in this situation
and i i liked the whole thing like i
wasn't sure what what was going to
happen there but i liked the whole thing
with the drone and the fact that you
know they took these opportunities to
set you up for things where you're like
oh god this is going to go so terribly
wrong and those things don't and then
they make room for other things to duck
in like you know the the whole thing
with the name guinam or whatever the the
you know the [ __ ] guy becoming you
know like one of the next steps in human
evolution like they're they're good i
think this was a
i know in previous episodes i've
compared like you know okay some of
these you know twists or events feel
more like a movie and some of them feel
more like oh wow that's kind of real and
that's kind of uh
you know a little more harsh and a
little more nuanced than you know movie
logic and i felt like this episode lived
very much in the sort of like real world
what would
happen kind of stakes true
and i really love the the
i love that we
they'll let certain characters pop in
like we didn't see the the guy live
streaming this episode even though we
didn't see him die in the last one but
you come back to the cop and the uh like
emt guy
and them going through the city and
finding the baby and things like that
like i i like how the
scope of the stories we're following
grows sort of subtly as it also gets
paired down with who dies yeah yeah it
was really quirky
it is yeah when they were running
through the city yeah it was like
unusually quirky i haven't seen footage
sped up to that extent in a long time
yeah yeah
that was a little jarring to me at the
moment yeah i enjoyed it but it also
felt like oh really sometimes i
i think the thing with the comedy of
where it could be a little hit or miss
is it starts feeling like a a beat of we
need some comedy in here
to light in the mood to provide some
release before we go back to tension
yeah
or to keep some engagement as soon as
the comedy feels like a note infused
yeah versus like
something naturally coming out of the
characters not always i'm not gonna i'm
gonna specify that it's not always
feeling like it's it's uh it's just
something that they're just interjecting
because they feel like they got to yeah
but sometimes it does uh but that's
still really amusing it was funny
uh they don't you don't see how they get
out of that car situation i thought that
was interesting because usually they let
you live in those moments to see how
they escape yeah
but it's fun how they did a wind-up with
the the baby themselves and now the baby
has a chance so i wonder what will
become of that and what if we're gonna
get like some flash forward or something
like that
at the end of this episode the end of
this season i do think chong son is
going to turn into a zombie i think he
will eventually get bit i think there's
just too much
hinting at that and i wonder what this
like evolution is of of it like was
there anything special come with it or
just develop
as right now it's registering as you
develop some type of immunity to it yeah
but it's not really registering as
something more than that
yeah is it like does the viru
what does learning the human
psyche and anatomy change make you a
psycho
or does it just make you better able to
live with it and not be a big deal yeah
yeah i'm curious about that too because
yeah i mean he's going through it and
the girl with the phones is definitely
going through it and that's the only
like i i'm
very excited to see them meet again
not excited that's the very wrong word
but i just don't hate that chomps my
favorite character yeah he's definitely
my favorite he's the most engaging for a
character like that who is intentionally
not vulnerable you need a character who
can have a lot going on underneath the
surface
when he's not talking or letting his
emotions out and i think out of all the
actors on the show he's the most
engaging when it comes to that
department of performance like he's
really great at the physicality he's
really like it looks like he's doing a
lot of his own stunts for for most of it
like a lot of the whole library sequence
was wonderfully composed yeah you know i
think what's really cool about the way
that what the show does is it uses it's
like i feel like they the the writers of
this show must have had some like
drawing board of like what does the
school have what let's how many of these
rooms can be utilized and how can we
stage a sequence around here and i think
they really utilize that to full effect
with their library scene
and but in terms of him as a character
like i really like the way they handle
that when he's like stuck alone he's
kind of becoming hopeless because this
episode one of the themes of this
episode obviously dealt with a lot of
you know
don't lose hope in a situation this dire
and he's a great reflection of that
while
we're talking about like ham-fisted like
with with prez
she's like pretty much stating the theme
of this episode
you know and she's she's talking about
the theme this episode they're having a
little bit of an existential debate
about the situation uh but with him you
see him regain his hope like what
motivates him
when he
thinks about um
oh my god we don't have the character
names to pull up what's wrong
oh his girl hanzo yeah andre i believe
so yeah um what he's thinking about her
when he's stuck in the
yeah the whole when he's stuck in the
event what do you call that like an
access chute or something or uh it's
probably the best description if it's
not that's a great thing you came up
with it it's just like pipes and just so
it must just be for like i don't know if
we got a tweak if we need to access the
plumbing yeah oh yeah like when he's
there and he
you know he's giving up hope and then he
uh like he could just fall if you wanted
to
and then he thinks about her and some
moments that we've seen in the show of
just him watching her and the feelings
he had during those moments
and then the the thought of like his
friend dying and like that could happen
to her could happen to him it's like you
see in that moment he has to get back to
her
and so i thought that was a really you
see his motivation to live is is coming
from there yeah so i thought like when
talking about the theme of hope you know
he he represented that the most
in there whereas everything else is
really like
bleak and then you see
the students in the in the classroom
they're stuck in also
trying their their absolute
best because it seems to this episode is
a tug and pull of like helping how much
hope can you maintain in a hopeless
situation yeah
yeah
and uh yeah they do a great job at
exercising those emotions man it's it's
really strong and i think all the actors
are really good too they're all they're
all really
believe to my understanding you know a
lot of the times the criticism can come
in the form of
you know you don't speak their language
so you don't really know how their
delivery is but i don't know it's like
when that's why i'm picking up a lot
more on like body language and like
someone is fascinating to watch even
when they're not talking
and the guy who plays chong song
especially is is incredibly fascinating
and and you know what that regard i hate
the character
but he does a very effective job that
bullying
he's incredibly effective and it's like
he wanted to rule the school and now he
feels like he can
you know like he that moment where he's
like i'm king of the school now yeah
literally nothing can touch me now i can
rile up the zombies walk around free
yeah it's like you saw the effect of
just causing some noise uh that's
so eerie so sinister yeah it's a great
it's a great it's a great use too of
your
you know a lot of times
a conflict that can happen in terms of
audience correlation with a zombie
property
is
are the zombies the threat now or is it
the humans and word how much focus do
you give to each one because you get
used to the zombies and really it's
humanity that's the threat so there's
something interesting they did here by
making the bully the the main bully at
least
the one who is immune to the zombies
yeah
because now you're kind of doing both
but but we have to see what the
evolution ultimately is yeah still make
you want to like feed on blood but at
that point there's the vampire you know
yeah but either way i mean it speaks to
that sort of randomness of life and it
you know goes kind of again i mean you
know for as much of a fist pump moment
of as it is when we think he dies you
know yeah like the the genetic lottery
you know and that's a bit of a movie
thing being that his you know like a
very much victim of his and then him
both have this link
but also i feel like it does go to
support that like life randomness of
like ah
then this terrible person got off
scot-free by chance you know i like the
motif of cutting back to the the
recording footage of when running the
test virus yes i think that's actually
used well and they know when to
implement the footage because they could
have implemented that with uh
with the girl who's uh suicidal uh they
could have implemented it there but they
let it they let the mystery percolate a
little bit more and then they reveal it
here and i think that's really effective
so i think the way they use that is
they know it's a very expositional tool
to use but they know when to use it to
the point where it doesn't become abused
yeah it feels like it's appropriate and
it makes sense and yeah the
yeah it's strengthened by the fact that
they let you have that moment last
episode of going what what what just
happened with her oh but there's a bunch
else going on you know and then you come
back to it here for clarification i
think though what i
something about that i i really
appreciate about this show is i'm never
disinterested when we cut to a different
set of characters
now there's not i can't think of one
plotline or group where i'm like ah you
can kind of board when we cut yeah yeah
yeah yeah admittedly like the like the
students
were they're not the most they're not
i'm not saying they're not interesting
it's just i they've done such a good job
in elevating the adult stories yeah that
i'm kind of more interested when we're
cutting to them to see what's going on
because there seems to be more
advancement where right now our students
are kind of just stagnant in this one
spot yeah where little to no plot
advancement can happen
so they kind of just take time to
ruminate over a [ __ ] up life
kind of earn those wisdom points by
having deep existential crises yeah i
still like them a lot i do i still think
they're really interesting um you still
feel the tension with that this is yeah
the adult story lines you're able to
advance and chong son who's like out on
his own you're able to advance the plot
while advancing character simultaneously
so i think in these last two episodes
it's kind of been the other stories that
have been more interesting but that's
not to say that the stuff with the
students i'm not like oh wait let's just
write them out of the show yeah let's
focus on things boring yeah i'm not
gonna say that nah
and i like how i like how capable this
they they flesh out the students too
like they're really smart
you know like even with the archer uh
characters i like even they're like
they're super interesting you know
they are a little bit action hero
as yeah but they're they're something
that's kind of when they're always
lining up back to back and like firing
in unison with each other
but that's what i mean by how this show
is kind of doing like all the zombie
[ __ ] except maybe we haven't got it it's
just like guys with guns mowing them
down yeah you know and i feel like we're
kind of headed there at that point yeah
we'll get there but even with them there
is that like they are like the zombie
land characters you know what like not
fully because they're way less comedic
and way less outlandish in personality
yeah
however there are like a group of four
people on their own two boys two girls
and then one's like a lot more timid
well the other one's a lot more
confident yeah totally no no
i wonder if there's any element of that
that's like some kind of subtle uh nod
to them because aren't they the ones who
even name check zombieland or no no no
that's when they're doing that
but still but even still yeah i would
imagine that there's some tangential
like nod there and everyone has a good
motive you know so i i i'm really
impressed with the show there's not
if if anything
if i don't like something in this in an
episode it's usually some isolated
moment that i forget about by the time
we're done watching it yeah absolutely
it's usually like a tiny thing that i
like
like here right now i'm like i'm sure
there was something here that i didn't
really care for but i can't i can't call
it to mine yeah it's washed away by all
the other things that work really really
well yeah yeah so i don't know i think
the development of how they
build the world
in the school around the school
uh
yeah it's very it's really interesting
stuff and it is what keeps it
interestingly focused at the school is
like this is where it all started
this is yeah this is ground zero
yeah
so
oh boy yep we're gonna say boring ass
episode boring episode
only good part was when that guy
switched chairs at the restaurant only
good mo that's actually like a look so
great that's such a great detail
and all it allows and and it's funnier
too because it it it is like it's such
an in the moment i wonder if it was
almost improvised or something but also
it creates like the zombies show up at
the window like a classic zombie movie
and it just allows you to pan slightly
away from them yeah and so like there's
even comedy in the camera motion as well
as just the very uh identif uh
identifiable humanity in that little
tiny choice yeah so great
all right guys well
thanks so much for being here really
appreciate uh
we appreciate you joining us on this
journey and we'll
talk to you soon
[Music]